es ist immer eine mega gute idee seine
waschmaschine an zu haben wenn man ein
video drehen möchte
hey leute ich es wieder reza schah und
natürlich ist pflanzt sie auch am
staatsakt hallo es ist natürlich nicht
der echte pflanze und ich bin natürlich
nicht die echte sascha aber als ich
dieses video ist fertig geschrieben habe
ist mir aufgefallen das ist ein
ziemliches sascha video sein wird falls
ihr das gar nicht kennen sie ist eine
investigative journalistin die wirklich
fantastischen content nach gegen
eigentlich alles ich finde dass seriöse
ist nicht nötig haben ein abo system
einzurichten also sie ist nicht wirklich
gegen alles aber sie ist ganz gerne
sieht es ganz gerne sieht es ganz gut
und es macht sie fast also alleine für
den tag wenn ihr seid könnt ihr jetzt
schon dem video einen daumen nach oben
geben und diesen kanal abonnieren um
mich zu unterstützen jetzt reden wir
nicht mehr überrascht ich wollte
eigentlich aus diesem video ein ich
kaufe alles was mir in paris werbung
vorgeschlagen wird video machen wir
werden gleich schon merken was das
problem mit diesen werbungen ist aber
was ist bitter ist eigentlich hinter das
ist das paradies für in terrier make up
und fashion inspiration wenn ich anderen
raum dekorieren möchte oder fashion &
make-up ideen brauchen gehe ich
natürlich auf diese app denn sie ist
voll mit kreativen content und werbung
alle apps natürlich in die werbung auf
interesse ist einfach anders ich kann
nicht ganz genau sagen woran es liegt
aber es ist so ein gefühl von der
algorithmus kennt mich nicht und ich bin
es nicht gewohnt weil jeder algorithmus
kennt mich und weiß was ich kaufen
möchte ich habe das gefühl dass sie sich
entwurf unsicherheiten von frauen
beziehen also die wir haben können gelbe
zähne cellulite dünnes haar oder
einfetten
obwohl das nicht mehr ganz so noch in
sicherheit früher wurde ich noch dafür
gehänselt aber heute haben wir den cache
aber überraschung keine sorge es gibt
für alles ein wundermittel diese
produkte können wirklich innerhalb von
kürzester zeit und ohne mühe alle deine
problemchen wegzaubern vielleicht weiße
algorithmus wirklich zu wenig über mich
außer dass ich eine frau ende 20 bin und
was sollte eine frau ende 20 denn volvo
seinen grünen anti pickel stirbt der
mitesser in leinsamen verwandelt ohne
wird also offen und ehrlich haben ein
video über diesen grünen pickel stift
gemacht und das ist wirklich halt
einfach betrug und ich hatte sogar
jemand in meiner familie der diesen
stift kaufen wollte weil die werbung
kalt das so gerät hat diesen betrug
wundermittel und ich würde lügen wenn
ich mich nicht selber über solche
produkte freuen würde die irgendwelche
körper eigenschaften innerhalb von fünf
minuten optimieren aber das ist halt
nicht realität und ich finde es
überhaupt nicht schlimm dass man an sich
arbeiten möchte und irgendwas
aufhübschen möchte solange das noch in
einem gesunden rahmen ist und man sich
dreimal die woche unters messer legt
oder jedem trend hinterher läuft aber
dieser drang zum perfektionismus it auf
dieser plattform so viel operiert und
die werbung pusht das noch viel mehr
oder frag ich will das so eine plattform
wie pinterits die ja wirklich ein sehr
unschuldiges image hat ich mein ich guck
da osterdeko na und dass die das dann so
selbstverständlich diese werbung da
verteilen es dauert wirklich nicht lange
bis ich auf solche werbung stoße nehmen
wir mal diese werbung von filiz berlin
oder steckt berlin im namen das muss gut
sein hier wird den lippen plumber also
ein lippen
aufprall ums ding damit beworben aber
das tut voll weh das ergebnis soll trotz
der schmerzen gut sein aber ist es das
wert ich mein budget schmerzen und es
tut so weh aber ich glaube das ist mein
neues lieblingsprodukt felice berlin ist
auch nicht der hersteller ihr könnt es
euch wahrscheinlich schon denken es ist
ein weiterer shop der alibaba produkte
weiterverkauft bin mir nicht mehr sicher
ob die den selber einkaufen oder ob das
nicht wieder so eine vermittlungs seite
ist wo dann einfach irgendwo der versand
stattfindet aber du bist so diese seite
die das einfach fertig auch amazon
gibt's diesen lippen planbar natürlich
auch aber für 12 euro statt 23 komisch
und auf der alibaba seite ist herzlich
bio und für vegane kleine lippen die
merkt schon hier stimmt etwas nicht und
so skeptisch solltet ihr nicht nur bei
produkten sein sondern auch bei
bezahlvorgängen oft bekommt man das
angebot produkte jetzt zu kaufen und
später zu bezahlen also ratenzahlungen
zu machen da bekommt man immer ganz toll
versprechungen von null prozent
finanzierungen und am ende weiß man gar
nicht was man überhaupt alles abbezahlt
und was für kosten auf einen zukommen
und annie fällen hilft ihr bei genau
diesen schwierigkeiten
heute will ich euch etwas vorstellen was
euch wirklich helfen kann er lief in
helft euch nämlich zu sparen wenn ihr
ratenzahlungen habt sie denken nämlich
die zinsen auf euren ratenkäufen so dass
ihr geld spart und schneller wieder
schuldenfrei seit heutzutage bieten
viele websites ratenzahlung beim
checkout an und 47 prozent aller
deutschen haben schon mal was auf raten
gekauft was viele nicht wissen und ich
definitiv auch nicht wusste dass man
dabei einen kredit aufnehmen bei dem man
bis zu 20 prozent zinsen zahlen könnte
ich habe in meinem leben schon leider
viele schlechte erfahrungen mit
ratenzahlungen finanzierung mitbekommen
zum glück musste ich diese fehler nie
selber machen sondern habe sie bei
anderen gesehen und konnte daraus lernen
und ich bin zum glück seit einigen
jahren in einer finanziellen situation
wo ich eher von ratenzahlungen absehe
und etwas direkt bezahlen weil ich ja
auch kann und reflexion dieser stelle
aber wenn das portemonnaie auch bei mir
früher kleiner waren kommt man in diese
situation ist man etwas haben möchte und
dann geht es halt irgendwie nicht und
dann wird da so 0% ding angeboten oder
irgendwie jetzt kaufen später zahlen da
ist man natürlich dann versucht das auch
zu machen und wenn man das dann gemacht
hat und merkt oh mist was ist eigentlich
gerade los ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo
oben und unten sagt kann anhaltende
helfen und ich kann euch das wirklich
ans herz legen denn die findet nämlich
eine finanz apps checkt ob die
bedingungen von eurem ratenkauf auch
fair sind und wenn nicht dann senken sie
nämlich die zinsen von bestehenden
ratenkäufen und eliminieren die gebühren
für euch ist klingt jetzt vielleicht
also diesen trocken aber sie haben den
effektivzins ihrer deutschen kunden um
durchschnittlich 40 prozent senken
können und was wirklich sie zu bedienen
ich zeige euch ganz kurzfristig ihr
ladet euch ganz einfach die enev in app
herunter und wählt aus wer euer
kreditgeber ist im nächsten schritt lade
die ein dokument foto oder screenshot
hoch auf welchem ersichtlich ist wie
hoch ihr noch abzuzahlen der kredit ist
dann könnt ihr noch einen rabattcode mal
wanne eingeben und erhaltet 20 euro
abzug eures noch abzuzahlen den kredit
die bekommt nur ein angebot wenn eine
von euch wirklich helfen kann zu sparen
ihr könnt in ruhe überlegen ob ihr es
annehmen wollte und nur wenn ihr das tut
wird der ratenkauf abbezahlt und ihr
zahlt dann weniger zinsen wie ihr seht
es gibt dabei nicht zu verlieren also
versucht es einfach mal geht auf n tv.de
und stellt eure anfrage es ist natürlich
kostenfrei und unverbindlich im sommer
einmal zurück zu unseren shady shops
bevor ich mit dem hier weitermache
verließ berlin ist natürlich nicht der
einzige shop der mit einem tollen stadt
nahmen wir haben auch noch wendiger
berlin also alles tolle berliner
unternehmen bestimmt super start ups
aber bei wenn den haben wir das problem
ist sie nicht mal ein impressum haben
also es ist da hat einfach jemand
vergessen dass auszufüllen ist aber ja
kein problem bei 12.000 zufriedenen
kunden und so einer tollen
kundenberaterinnen hier da da vertraue
ich dem shop einfach in den air berlin
verkauft hier natürlich wieder ein ganz
tolles produkt was auch superschnelle
basis die lange fingernägel machen du
musst nicht eine stunde lang im
nagelstudio steht oder drei monate deine
fingernägel wachsen lassen ich weiß
nicht wie lange die fingernägel nach
drei monaten werden ich finde poligen
igel eigentlich ganz interessant aber
sorry also das sieht einfach nicht das
sieht nicht gut aus aber es ist
unglaublich wie schnell das
funktionieren von bei berlin ein bruder
verkaufsgrund ist haben wir auch justus
börlind auch ein toller job um noch mal
auf finanzierungen zu kommen natürlich
später bezahlen mit kleiner natürlich
kauft kauft hans ja auch später bezahlen
aber über klar wollen wir gar nicht
anfangen komisch dass lust in berlin ein
impressum aus den niederlande haben und
die information von lieferanten und
vermarkter h sind in china ok
superklasse dann haben wir das jetzt
geklärt ist wie ein haufen an shops die
alle so super shady sind wo ich mich
einfach nur frage
weiteres warum bekommt ihr nicht einfach
lecker werbung rein also so wie
instagram ticker und alle anderen seite
warum ist pinter ist wirklich das mekka
für schlechte werbung aber es gab ein
shop der mich wirklich überzeugt hat das
produkt musste ich unbedingt
ausprobieren denn es wird mir wirklich
jedes mal wenn ich auf tour bin
vorgeschlagen das make up von
matthias ich weiß nicht wie es
ausgesprochen wie nokia verspricht dass
sie einen perfekten hautton finden in
nur 60 sekunden nach diesem schnellen
teil beantwortete die fragen welches
gesicht bist du ende bekommt die
perfekte farbe vorgeschlagen ich habe
das produkt breit getestet
matthias 3 millionen diese werbung
matthias werbung ist wirklich so
dermaßen penetrant ich konnte nicht
anders sondern natürlich ist es auch
ihre matthias new york wie alle anderen
produkt aus berlin paris und london über
75 prozent der frauen benutzen
foundation fall würde ich auch da
schreibe ich meine dass ich nicht immer
den richtigen ton für meine hautfarbe in
der kamera jetzt gerade nicht aus ich
habe einen wärmeren haut und also wenn
ich ein spiegel gucke sich wärme aus der
gleiche liefern nation nicht an seinem
hals oder hand gelegen der farbton dort
es anders als in deinem gesicht rinke
dich fertig mit concealer motion browser
benutzen die foundation eine ganze woche
lang um festzustellen ob sie perfekt für
dich ins nach ganz vielen testfragen
habe ich hoffentlich jetzt meine
richtige foundation farbe gefunden ein
mal den pinsel auspacken der pinsel wird
irgendwie billiger aus als ich erwartet
habe most reviewed foundation online
also düsseldorf das heißt verpackung ist
mit mein gerät in rente von den heute
macht jetzt
guten eindruck das ist zb ein giorgio
armani und
armani hat nur hier so dieses logo vorne
aber ansonsten auch relativ schließlich
habe die farbe 60 und das ist das wo cup
lag das meer kapitän nach der anleitung
und tragen wir mal aufgehört sich sehr
nass auf der haut an und kalt ist gutes
zeichen angespannt das ding ist die
präsentieren sich ja selber so als ob
sie so mega gehabt sind auch mit der
ganzen tour ist werbung es wirkt so als
ob es so dass high produkte habe ich
kenne niemanden der das hat niemanden
oder mal darüber gesprochen hat oder so
also das ist so das geilste make up the
wall sind eigentlich wird doch alles
immer zum tik tok trennen wenn es gut
ist oder nicht ich glaube ich brauche
mehr als zwei punkten
meine hand könnte das glaube ich
erkennen es ist auf jeden fall eine
dunklere steht als ich eigentlich bin
oder meiner hand ist ich muss jetzt noch
ein bisschen warten wie das make-up sich
denn so verhält der erste eindruck
wirklich sehr gut der preis ist
unfassbar teuer 46 euro kostet dieses
mega und ich hab noch einen pinsel
gekauft für 45 euro ich weiß nicht was
mich geritten hat und ich war vom ersten
auftragen schon irgendwie überzeugt ich
weiß auch nicht ob gedacht das make up
wird vielleicht haben wir probleme haben
arbeit ließ und jetzt wo ich das nochmal
aufgetragen habe ich mal die kamera ein
bisschen dunkler ist ihr das noch besser
erkennen können ist es so oder bin ich
das noch nicht gewohnt dass ich kann es
nicht mehr es ist nicht also ich müsste
jedoch umso mehr licht wegnehmen oder
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist auch
einfach nicht meint wenn ich hier schön
das licht darauf knallen und sodann geht
es aber nicht
und 45 euro für pinsel tun immer noch
weh
90 euro ich möchte das video ein
bisschen positiv enden denn ich habe
auch eine andere sache ausprobieren die
ich aber nicht im pinterits shop gekauft
habe sondern es wurde mir einfach auf
interesse denn die vorgeschlagen und
zwar die kunst des corsa im kanal jemand
ausspricht die klammers von kelly ich
hab sie geklaut interest aufgemacht und
schon gehts ab 10 uhr sprechen
wahrscheinlich fällt aus und da ist es
wieder
matthias harder sind die vorjahr weist
das ist wohl die einfachste anleitung
hier haben wir mein jahre gouache sein
was ist echt schade ich weiß es nicht 18
euro 90 was ich jetzt von gore jahr
gelernt habe
geschah geschah was ich von gorgier
gelernt hat man braucht auch eine neue
also ein face habe ich jetzt ein
organischer julio ball genommen und das
öl habe ich für 14 euro 99 bekommen
wieder mal fast 40 eure menge sich
interessiert also geschah macht man auch
ein gereinigtes gesicht und man benutzt
eine art von öl oder irgendwas damit das
schön gleitet das ding soll auch für
produkte gut sein die man auf die haut
macht um sie dann intensiver
einzuarbeiten in die haut machen sie es
einmal zusammen ich hab es schon ein
paar mal gemacht und ich bin ehrlich mit
euch kann den halb verstehen ich habe
ich das gefühl das ist dieses wasser aus
dem gesicht so ein bisschen weg macht
und man sieht ein bisschen definierter
und dann natürlich auch ein bildung
seien aber ich habs jetzt so fünfmal
schon testweise gemacht und ja ich bin
überzeugt kann von einer seite anfangen
und dann die andere seite machen ich
mache mal beide seiten parallelen und
man arbeitet anscheinend von unten nach
oben und von oben nach unten ich zeige
euch hier sein
und der druck soll so sein dass es
spürbar ist weil man soll es nicht so
ist so extrem drücken sondern eher so
gleiten schieben zum tat einfach seine
tat mit einem gesicht so und eigentlich
hier an der seite
noch mal so unter druck schießt das
wasser und die giftstoffe und was nicht
alles in deiner haut ist zu den nymphen
und dann ziehst du es runter aber hier
sind so die lumpen und dann hilfst du
bist das abläuft ganz ehrlich ich kann
auch keine anleitung geben weil die
anleitung schon wieder anders ist als
die die ich vorher gesehen habe eine
sache die mir noch dabei aufgefallen ist
immer wenn ich das hier so zum ordern
mache ich das gefühl dass ich dann noch
ein bisschen trotzen muss ich mache
deutlich musste ein pluspunkt ich finde
es hat was extrem negative wenn ich das
mache dann fühle ich mich wirklich
entspannt und sonst ganz natürlich hier
geplatzte wann
ich bin schon irgendwie ein fan davon
weil denkt okay alles was man reduzieren
kann ohne irgendwelche ubs hat man schon
machen und manchmal hat man ja so tage
da sie die haut oder das gesicht einfach
schön definiert irgendwie hat man so ein
globi day hinter tag an dem man sich
einfach irgendwie nicht ganz so wohl
fühlt da sind einfach mehr falten da
oder man hat nicht so einen strahlenden
tag oder vielleicht ist das gesicht ein
bisschen auf geprüft und ich finde und
an solchen tagen dann so was machen kann
dass man sich irgendwie besser fühlte
das ja so was gut ist also wenn das
nicht mal ein glow in mein gesicht ist
dann weiß ich auch nicht weit ja ich
finds gut die werbung mich gekriegt aber
ich musste auch nicht auf einer shell
die seite etwas bestellen ich hab's dann
einfach googlen und habe es dann auf
einer nicht so schnell die seite
gestellt so als fazit wir leben in so
einer konsum gesteuerten welt und da
irgendwo ist natürlich verständlich sind
alles kleine elstern die glitzernde
sachen in ihrem nest haben wollen und
ich glaube es ist auch nicht richtig
dass immer zu kritisieren dass die leute
halt dieses bedürfnis haben aber ein man
muss wirklich heutzutage aufpassen
gerade bei diesem ganzen
werbeversprechungen hierauf pinter ist
so krass gelogen sind nicht mal so wie
man es noch irgendwie aus dem fernsehen
kennt oder wenn influenza irgendwas in
die kamera hält nicht das gefühl da wird
ja wirklich content produziert er
offensichtlich liegt also offen und
ehrlich hat ja auch so dass sind die
eingeschaltete langsam gewesen die dann
in der werbung so drauf geklebt wurden
ja mcdonald's sprüht seine bürger mit
haarspray an wenn sie in der werbung
zeigen irgendwie ist es wahrscheinlich
auch schon ein altes ding ich möchte
euch nur sagen passt auf alle sachen die
ihr kaufen wohl denkt zwei mal darüber
nach wann geht einfach zu einer frau die
euch im make up laden die perfekte
heraussucht und macht nicht den besten
tag man kann viele schöne dinge über das
internet machen aber das nicht und jetzt
bleibt mir nichts anderes zu sagen als
bis zum nächsten video und ich gehe
jetzt mein gesicht waschen jesse
euroshop in grünwald